CASSIE KOZYRKOV: With almost
500 sessions at NEXT 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see How AI is
Transforming the Enterprise,
then stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AI is no longer science fiction.
It's here, and it's up to
you to be creative with it.
But what does that look
like in practice, and how
do you actually
use it to transform
your industry at scale?
If you want to take a
peek behind that curtain
and find out how familiar
enterprises adopt
AI with game-changing results,
then this talk is for you.
It brings you cloud customer
stories of frustrations
and triumphs-- stories that
are deep, practical, inspiring,
and very real.
You'll meet Fox Sports,
an Australian media
and entertainment company that
uses AI to transform sports
by alerting fans when something
exciting is about to happen.
Join Hulu for a
behind-the-scenes
look at data quality
and see how AI
can be used to generate better
data for other AI applications,
while bringing more joy to the
work of their customer service
agents.
Now, that's
creativity going meta.
Once you've got your creative
vision and your data,
what's next?
You're going to need a model.
A model is just a
fancy word for recipe.
Now, traditional AI
was all about making
every recipe yourself.
But what if the model that
you need already exists?
Why reinvent the
concept of pizza
when you can use your
favorite chef's pizza recipe?
Well, it turns out that's
exactly what Google Cloud's
Machine Learning
APIs are all about.
They are recipes that we have
made for you so you can just
get cooking.
We've done the machine
learning heavy lifting.
Now you can just plug and play.
Though machine learning
APIs make it easy,
you can use them to achieve
incredibly visionary things.
You will be blown
away and inspired
to hear about Unilever's
journey with our APIs,
and you might just raise an
eyebrow at their stunning ROI.
Borrowing existing
solutions is great,
but some industries
are all about creating
proprietary recipes
from scratch.
Finance is a great example.
You'll hear the world's largest
asset manager, BlackRock, dive
into how it uses AI to
stay on top of its game
and navigate its
challenges, including
the crucial need
for transparency,
the dangers of
unjustified complexity,
and new directions
for their future--
like natural
language processing.
Scale is in Google's
DNA, and it's
extremely important
to the customers
you'll meet in this talk.
So scaling up is a huge thing.
But running AI at
global scale doesn't
mean one size has to fit all.
Disney's story is all
about personalization.
They were one of
the first customers
to try our Recommendations
AI before its public release
at Google NEXT.
Now, less than a
year later, they
are successfully serving a
magical personalized experience
for users on their
Shop Disney site.
You'll hear insights into their
testing practices, the power
of anonymized data, and why we
know that Eeyore sleep masks
really don't go
with Darth Vader.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link
in the description
below, and don't forget to
subscribe to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
NEXT Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]